through it like two or three
times. Just sort of went through
it. I did not see it the thing
here, though. I think Sarah is.
People are disappointed not
about the amount because I think
it's a it's a it's a good
amount, but that the people who
actually need to hear this. The
Fox News viewers won't get to
hear it because it's monitored.
We looked at, say we checked the
facts news website last night.
Um there was no mention of it on
their homepage. The article they
do have written doesn't even say
how much money fox is paying so
who actually wins here. It's
interesting. I actually was
sitting next to a factions
reporter in court, and I was
watching them diligently take
notes and just having them be in
court. To me felt like a little
bit of a level of
accountability. Their media
analyst Howie Kurtz, did end up
covering it towards the end of
the trial, he said. In the
beginning, he wasn't allowed to,
but to your point about not
making an apology, you know, the
thing that actually makes me
more upset is they don't have to
issue any corrections or any
right traction in a journalistic
entity. If I get something
wrong, I have to correct it.
That's the way that it goes. But
to your point about what are the
broader implications here. You
have to remember. Fox is facing
many defamation suits. It's not
just a million. They have a suit
from smartmatic. They also have
a suit with one of their own
producers that's suing them,
claiming that they misled her
during testimony. And so what
happens is when you settle a
case like this, you're setting a
precedent for how you legally
are going to likely need to
handle all of the other chances
in this case, we know that what
they're willing to do is pay up
in order to make sure their
exact never have to face a
trial. You can best believe
leave that smartmatic who's by
the way, their lawsuit is much
bigger than dominions. Yeah you
leverage the discovery that they
found during the dominion
hearing to strengthen their case
, and they're going to leverage
the fact that facts just made a
huge payout. To a different
competitor when they're trying
to negotiate for their
settlement. If they do all been
here before, and I mean, not a
lot, but where you've had to. We
had to go on air and say even if
we didn't do it, we start. We
regret the mistake. We
apologize, whatever. And we
correct it and move on there.
They don't don't care by the way
like viewers don't care if you
get something wrong, it builds
credibility to own your mistake
. A great point. Ken, just can
we talk about smartmatic toward
$7 billion defamation lawsuit to
Sarah's point, their attorney
essentially said yesterday we
got all this discovery from
dominion. We're gonna use that.
So what is it? You think this
case settles as well? Mhm. Oh I
is a smart Maddox lagging behind
. They were appealed. I think
there were New York and you get
intermediate intermediate,
appellate right immediately on
any motion there, so their
discovery I think it's just
starting. But there's no way
they're not going to capitalize
on what's out there and
interesting point because Sarah
brought up the abbey Grossberg
tapes right there, producer
right and think about this
because this deuteronomy when
you ask what's going on the
special master appointment
occurs yesterday afternoon. I
believe judge Davis rules on
this. Shortly thereafter, we get
the settlement announcement and
I'm wondering how deep those
tapes going, what's in there? So
they've got a treasure trove
here. Now listen, whether it's
admissible in their case or not
two different issues. But at the
very least, it's going to give
them a very broad set of
boundaries to design an attack
on their own discovery, uh,
front and there's just no way
that it doesn't help them
immensely. It's honestly like
having a peek behind the curtain
. It makes your job a lot
easier. I can't see in the
context. I don't know much about
smartmatic in the sense of how
they designed their damages. You
know, um geminis was a pure
breakdown of business damages.
Right resident hogan. I got like
60 million. Uh non monetary,
right. So at the end of the day
, we'll see how valid the
numbers but I cannot see fox in
the wake of this protracted that
and not trying to resolve it
doesn't make sense, right? Yeah.
Sort of clean the house up
completely, uh, put it all the
rest. Um but who knows? Maybe
smart medical won't let him
listen. We're discussing all of
this, but that is what
settlements do you negotiate? We
don't have to do this. We're
going to pay you this in order